on a volé la joconde nous sommes le 21
août 1911 lors de sa ronde un gardien du
louvre découvre que la joconde a été
volé tout le monde est suspecté les
visiteurs les employés du nouveau mais
aussi des artistes comme pablo picasso
ou encore le poète guillaume apollinaire
qui va même être emprisonné quelques
jours il faut attendre décembre 1913
pour que vincenzo peruggia un vitrier
italien qui travaillait au louvre pousse
la porte d'alfredo jerry un antiquaire
florentin à qui il souhaite vendre un
tableau l'antiquaire identifie la toile
et prévient la police française peruggia
arrêté et condamné à un an de prison il
expliquera avoir volé l'oeuvre se
sentant humilié de l'avoir en terre
étrangère la mona lisa elle retourne au
louvre en janvier 1914 et elle est
placée depuis sous haute protection
petite anecdote c'est ce vol qui a rendu
ce tableau si célèbre